how can this stream not have 20 000
viewers
this is the biggest event of the year
i'm scared i'm actually kind of
terrified because tagi's beaten me many
times
with just normal normal peace
distribution um when i've been
blindfolded
like i think my my goal is to win at
least actually is to draw at least one
game
not to lose 10 in a row um
what was it it was a few weeks ago i
made a poll
of what the match format should be
whether i should have just the blindfold
just queen odds or both and the
overwhelming majority
voted on both so here i am
um i'm i'm scared but
i think i'm ready yeah if you're new
here
to the stream or new on twitch this is
um
this is a bit different than than usual
i guess every stream is slightly
different than usual
so this will be the first game i should
turn back on the speech
speech synthesis ready i don't know if
tiger's oh tiger's ready okay
okay goodbye world i have to focus
really have to focus
so my this is my lifetime score taki had
like a nice streak where he
beat me so many games oh people that
people can kind of see go
toggy i got bits just for this chair oh
dear
oh just for this chair okay all right
let's focus
three plus five should i maybe i should
upgrade like a little bit more
split seconds are critical
okay game one
all right v3
let's say focus e5
e5 this should be two bishop e2 oh dear
get him e-r-i-c-c-c knight c6
e3 okay so we're gonna play a hippo
type thing or larson attack whatever
this is called
d5 d5 bishop b5 let's be aggressive
let's see his defensive capabilities
bishop d7 i don't really want to trade
actually
even though it wins upon actually let's
point the pawn bishop takes c6
bishop takes c6 bishop takes e5 okay
fly on the pawn at the cost of trading
bishop prince what bishop d6 bishop d6
bishop takes g7 yes okay winning more
more material let's go
leetsku
still have to be careful queen g5 yeah i
have to be very careful
oh that was a really good move
ah
that was a really good move okay bishop
h8 bishop takes h8 well maybe toggy saw
all that ahead too
queen takes g2 knight c3
queen takes h1 queen side casper queen's
hanging eric
i know well it's gone but yeah i miss it
so much queen g2 queen g2
wants to win my f pawn let's play f4
f4 okay
queen side castles
oh that's legal
i guess that's legal i'll play
so i'll hmm bishop d4 bishop d4
okay i need a miracle this game
okay so i have a nice kind of pawn
island
so i guess bishops i think there's still
a knight on g8 queen takes h2
okay let's develop the knight f3 knight
f3
trying to control the center
i want to play 95 dwight two minutes
queen h5 wanted to win the queen too
there
hmm
so i have rook rook f1
and also
i guess rook f1
actually rook f1 doesn't quite work
uh what to do this night
i might have to try rook f1 though
i'll play rook f1 rook f1
tagging's moving quickly too so it's
difficult two minutes ten seconds
still above two minutes later that's
good two minutes 37 seconds
more time though
okay so at least i'm controlling the
center i'm talking
what b6 b6
interesting
there's a bishop bishop's on c6
ah so i see his plan
i'm gonna play 92 knight e2 give the
bishop some room to move back
at some point i have to just attack
bishop b5
oh it's kind of a skewer pin let's play
d3
d3
bishop a3 check probably king d2
king d2 just defend everything with the
king
okay c5
yeah i guess i have bishop e5 here
bishop p5 so bishop e5
so it's a nice sort of structure at
least
box bishops are a bit misplaced
f6 ah i forgot f6 is legal
yeah because the knights on g8 i play
bishop a1
that's a sad move but what else to do
maybe he'll forget about my bishop
it can be a sniper in the corner c4
c4
that's probably a fine move let's play
knight
e d4 knight edd4
so just centralizing the knights
bishop before check
wait there's no oh there's no e pawn
wait bishop b4 check let's play c3 c3
so now both bishops are attacked i think
my bishop is really sad on a1
but i might be winning something
white one minute 34 seconds okay
black one minute 23 seconds i'm up in
time let's go
yeah both bishops hanging bishops e5
bishop c5
is the pawns on b6 i believe
knight c6 what
oh no bishop takes c6 oh the bishop was
on b5 i thought the bishop was on c6 i
forgot it moved
so i just lost a piece oh that's so bad
no okay let's um let's fight b4
b4
yeah both bishops were hanging i just
i've forgot about the place from the
light squared bishop
bishop d6 bishop d6 okay
i have to bring the bishop back bishop
e2 into the game
say take d3
playwright f2 r2
this is like weirdly symmetrical king on
d2 i think i have pawns on like b4 c3 e3
f4
king d7 d7 so defending the bishop
play a3 a3 over defend my pawn i want to
play c4
rookie 8
play c4 c4
a5
oh it's not over bishop b4 or not bishop
before bishop c3 bishop c3
i'm defending the pawn
white one minute ten sec it takes b4
a takes b4 okay
nine h6 yeah good move
um i think i can take this
can take d3
it's it's very risky though not g4
my g4 is a good move
play rookie two rookie two
as knight is going to be for what
bishop check e4
okay king d2
f5
good move
not sure what to do here let's play
knight i guess might be five
knight b5
bishops queen of seven
another good move three nine of three
h5
can you see one king c1
h4 ready two
knight takes e3 c5
trying to attack trying
c5 d7 right v takes c5
rook e6 right e6
plane knight e5 knight b5
knight c4
that's getting really weird let's play
rook t4
h3 yeah that was a little bit scared of
that
let's take on c4 repeat c4
bishop takes f4 check
bishop takes f4 check oh the bishop's
unpinned ah
king b2
h2 oh dear
pawn is about to become a woman
uh d4 default check
e7
play bishop
wait
works on e6 let's play vision before
bishop b4
don't promote don't promote
also where's my king c6 rook c6
interesting 97 987 kings on b2 i think
what does that say play c6 check c6
check
king f6
bishop c3 bishop p5
rookie 6 check check
king g5 bishop bishop takes e5
h1 promotes the queen oh king's on b2
then okay
still in trouble though i have a pawn on
e3
bishop f4
i forgot the knight took it knight um
let's play knight b5 knight b5
rook takes c6
[Music]
rookie two
rookie six
hmm
g2 queen a7 checkmate checkmate
yes that was the first game i was trying
to create skill mates
rick b6 i wanted to no it was impossible
what was this game good game tagging
tacky goes up by one oh let me maybe
move it
people can see the the full score
yeah there we go
okay okay um that was the first game
that felt like an eternity b3
um i'll send a rematch as soon as i
recover
i mean
the opening gave me confidence
this was really bad though like i knew
the bishop was on b5 i just
i was still seeing because the bishop
was on c6 like earlier
and it was a hallucination of some sort
but that was still a fight too
and if i took here yeah although offered
some better chances
curious if i missed anything
it's hard to push the pawn
i was happy with rook d6 is a nice
little tactic
i still seeing a phantom pawn here which
was taken ages ago
okay i i have one keyboard
not two keyboards all right so the goal
yeah the goal is to win at least one
game
okay let's um how to do this
i think the easiest way is is just to
send a rematch abort and then send
another rematch
so tag if you want to accept the rematch
let me turn back on this thing
i think my time my time management was
was decent that game
because yeah i lived on the increment at
least in the opening
let me go to port editor
right to play
okay
okay new challenge is being sent
okay if i'm white every game i guess i
can
i can fiddle around with opening
preparation i think i'll repeat the same
opening
b3 okay let's go oh did i turn on speech
sound no speech synthesis ready so the
speech
uh will activate the clock b6 bishop
bishop e2 e6 bishop b2 okay
king e7 king e7 oh he's giving me three
moves
e4 he's giving mercy one cloud oh he's
playing the long cloud
maybe not full mercy i guess i should be
terrified
wait that's a king seven right bishop e2
e4 e4 okay so he's thinking
e5 why three minutes two seconds
for e5 e5
knight c6 f4
okay so i actually like the fact we're
getting some closed position
knight f3 h5
h5 okay let's play maybe e2
p2
very soon d4 knight b4 like b4
oh it's trying to be annoying i guess
bishop d1
bishop d1 this is advantage of not
having a queen i can put my bishop
the bishop on d1 if i have the queen i
can do this move
b6 b6 play a3
a3
so hitting the knight knight c6
d4 okay so we get some nice kind of
advantage bishop e7 b7 okay
bring the bishop back to you
h4 h4
okay not afraid play knight bd2
d2
queen c8
queen c8 he's just playing really weird
moves
trying to to make me lose a position
you'll play rook c1 eventually c4
bishop h6
c4 uh he wanted to play okay that's why
he played queen c8
okay eventually i'll probably go for
like b4 b5
white two minutes 55 seconds
time is very two minutes 26 seconds
awesome
so i've been averaging just over five
seconds to move
rook h7 h7
i have knight g5
that's all my g5 doesn't do too much
i think i'll play it anyway though
knight g5
h8 the king's on e7 still
wait a minute i take on d5 see takes d5
i guess we're treating bishops
bishop takes e2 can take on cloud
delayed bomb cloud
i'm actually feeling good about this
position
feeling very good 98 yeah cause the
knight was attacked by the rook
he lays 98
i have a d6 check
d6 check let's go
so the queen's on c it's pinned uh or
the pawn is pinned to the queen by the
rook on c1
king d7 oh
now i can i can take on
on c7 i believe rick takes c7 check
queen takes c7 okay and now
dc7 can take c7
knights on d8 oh next time d8 defending
f7 and e6
but i've i finally won the queen this is
the first this is like a monumental
moment
i guess all moments are are all moments
monumental
maybe not
white two minutes nine seconds okay
black two minutes five seconds okay so
about equal
i'm hitting the knight here's why he's
sinking here
white one minute fifty-four seconds
can't take c7 oh it's my move oh rick
see one check okay check
let's play let's play b4 b4
g6
interesting
what's my plan
i actually don't know what my plan is
play king skinny three
king e3 bishop h6
f3 what
oh i have two knights on knight gf3 not
gf3
okay so i played king e3 to over defend
the f-pawn
okay so i'm basically just down the rook
here we've got one rook f1 it's a very
close position
rook hd8 h d8
i don't know what that does
oh oh the default's half open i was
still seeing a pawn on d5
that's not the case
i can take on each four knight takes h4
this may be a bad i should play g3
g5 what oh
g5 oh that's a good move
i'm playing knight f3 knight f3
then king e2 g takes f4 check
kimi 2. okay
some weird pawn structure
knight d5 what knight d5 d5 where's
other knight
knights on c6 okay
play knight b3
wait why can't i play knight b3
knight b3 is my knight already on b3
huh okay let's play rook c1
rook c1 you have played knight b3
earlier
i forgot about it rook g8
g8 it's taking f2 king d2
no no no i want to play king f2
take g2
oh it's really bad too
no d3 d3
there goes my bishop
oh i meant to defend the pawn let's play
um
wait so i i assume i have a knight on b3
knight b d2
d2 okay so i did i just forgot
okay i'm gonna need a miracle this game
rookie two
a2
i guess knight c4
knight c4
i kind of forgot that i have access to
d6
so that's my one hope
b5 knight d6
king c7 okay
i play d5
oh no the knights knights fly on d5
you can see seven can i play knight b5
knight takes v5 check sure king b6
knight d6 rook takes a3 check
kenny two
where's box i'll be rook on eight
rick takes f3 kin takes f3
knight takes d4 check oh we can move
king 2
f3 bishop to tag my rook
hey what do you want ready one
knight c2
king takes a three
knight c takes b4 let's see takes
b4 brook
rip b1 white 0 minutes 18 seconds
black one a5
don't i have an a1 oh he took it
um g1 rook g1
so i'm down i'm basically down two minor
pieces i think
pawns on a5 knight
ah there goes this pawn again
f7 was legal what was i typing
i think i tried i don't know what
happened oh i got raided
wait what oh thanks for the raid who
raided someone raided
um what does it say
oh my event list oh
my bad also a good game taggy
oh anna crowling thanks for the raid i
i didn't even realize that event list
was was missing
well welcome welcome to the stream
i appreciate it shout out to anna carmen
i really appreciate it
um i should make like a a special noise
for raids
oh that was a that was a close game too
so i wan i i felt so proud of my play
uh because i won the queen
yeah toddy played a slightly troll
opening
i was so proud of this so this is so
nice
the problem is like it kind of fizzled
and then yeah i didn't see this idea
soon enough
should have played knight knight c4 here
and then this was really bad i meant to
play king f2 the the d
the d key is too close to the f key
i was still down a rook though well play
target
yeah knight b3 was an attempt to just
defend like the potential weak pawn
but yeah not a not a good positional
move
for some reason i i still saw this
phantom pawn on d5
okay let's keep going
i feel like these games are close though
um
i mean or at least hard fought
i don't think i've had a winning like
completely winning position yet
oh people already saying hi to youtube
oh chat ask for king e2
oh i guess king e7 is the translation
okay
yeah we're going to keep the same time
format i actually like this time control
because increment is um
it's still possible to to gain time
okay let's do this
oh let's turn back on
this and
speech speech synthesis ready all right
game start let's do this
v3 okay only last two still plenty of
time to come back
does target have in mind this time
white three minutes zero seconds i guess
his clock doesn't start ticking
three e5 you fight bishop
f6 oh okay let's play e3 e3
knight c6 h3
i'll play a different setup this time
knight b4 again he's
being super aggressive let's play knight
a3 93
okay bishop d6 the d6
play g4 g4 i'm preparing queen e7
king side attack oh he's being very
sneaky
you can just play like bishop i wanted
to play bishop g2
hmm that's a very sneaky move
i think i'll play king d1 it's a weird
but king d1
it defends gets all the potential checks
[Music]
because yeah he set up this queen bishop
battery towards my knights
b6 b6
b6 b6 b6 or e6
no it has to be b6 b6 b6 okay
b6 uh i see his plan let's play bishop
g2
bishop g2 okay so preventing bishop b7
attacking israelites
oh the pawn so the pawn is still on d7
interesting
this will play knight might be five
knight v5
there's a weird opening so far bishop e7
knight e2 92
a6 c3 c3
i can't complain with opening though
don't mind this position
two minutes 28 seconds black
bishop there's before b4 okay so he
wants to trade let's play knight d5
knight d5 oh forking everything
you can probably defend but
yeah queen d6 a3 a3
bishop takes c2 wow
aggressive team d2 can take d2
slime pinned kind of
my g7 i have c4 here
c4
okay my rooks are connected the double
fiance
this is doing something to fight for the
center
knight a5 and knight a5 is a
a fine move i think i have to play king
c2 here king c2
just give away a pawn i'm defending the
b pawn which is important
knight takes d5 c bishop takes d5
[Music]
i wanna play rook rook d1 it doesn't
quite work though
maybe e4 doesn't work either
oh
now this is rough let's play um let's
play bishop d5 queen takes d5
oh he pre-moved okay
b3
this will play b4
b4
this is dangerous
okay so i have bishop on b29 then e2
roxanne
b3 check a1h1
as a little bit scared of that move
thinking c1 king c1
knight c4 b1
so trying to defend
white two minutes five seconds
black two minutes six seconds okay
knight takes b2 rook takes b2
queen takes a3 you see two
king c2 okay okay so i basically have a
knight for a
black has a bunch of pawns too
a5 so i still have a pawn on b4
i feel like every game toggy's trying to
like queen a rook pawn
that's annoying but b5 have to deal with
it
king e7 e7
queen c5
let's play still have a pawn e3 let's
play rook
d1 d1
rook hd8 hd8
f4 f4 oh no my e3 pawn
ah i have a pawn e3 right
i think i do
eiffel he's not taking it
uh let's play
play rook d5 let's attack
queen takes e3
[Music]
d2 oh i didn't i meant to play rook d3
that's okay
queen c5 d5
happy to repeat
oh queen f2 is check king's on c2
this is very very difficult dwight one
minute 56 seconds
plenty of time black one minute 11
seconds ooh okay
queen of two check ready too
tiggy's being careful
queen g3 queen g3 d3
rook d3 d3
just take my f pawn it's a free pawn
draw white queen enough to check
d2
or play queen e3 safe just a safe square
for the queen
queen takes d2 check oh he sacks it wow
both has gambit
king takes d2 a3 okay too
okay so i'm only down the exchange and a
bunch of pawns
c5 c5
95 here knight d5 check
check
i think there's still a palm on d7
no it takes b6 okay
look a b8 and c4 knight c4 check
check
king d5 king d5 okay um knight e3
probably i also have knight a3
kn83 knight t3 check
oh i hear the thunder
some
probably want to take the pawn first
f takes e5
okay replace v5
rook takes a3
b2 check
b2 check maybe king c1
king c1
run on a3 defending the knight on e3
rookie
each two attacking the pawn
interesting
so if i push
let's play essex he takes f6
rick takes h3 rookie 4 check
oh no my knight my knight
it's not defended
wait king e5 oh he doesn't take it
though okay
um e5
let's play yeah i don't see how to the
princess my t4 check check
king takes f6 knight d6
so black has pawns on c5 d7 h7 i believe
i have a pawn on g4 h5
really gh5
g takes h5
h5
thinking c2 how about king c2
king e6
rook a6 okay i'm fighting with every
resource i have
rook f8
94 check
king e5
hmm
knight d2 white one minute three seconds
plenty of time
black zero rookie two
hmm
this isn't good
can you see three i guess king c3
oh maybe wait
played rook h2 g5
g5 oh i didn't see there's a pawn on g5
yeah i have knight c4 check
knight c4 check we're gonna h2 pawn in
g5 okay
king of four
okay one
g4
wait did you play workout fate earlier
i forget where the rook is
g4 let's play um rook f1 rook f1 check
the rook battery be on f8
i can't plus track rook takes f8 yes
okay
okay so black still has three pawns
this could be a really long game d5
um d5
knight e5
g3
[Music]
check king of five
knight f3
king f4
rook f3 check
kim g4 rook g8 check
king f4 rook f8 check
kim g4 knight e5 check
kim g5
king f3 i think that works on each three
if i'm not mistaken
c3 play
king of five
[Music]
knight d3
d4 rook c5 check
king f6 king g2
rook h8
king takes g3 rook g8 check
king f3
rook g5 for g5
okay um let's play rook c4
rook c4
d5
king e4
wanna play king d3
kv6 kd3
k5
rxe5 check
we're we're going to get rook rook and
knight versus rook d6
d6 favorite c4 rook c4
white zero minutes 36 seconds plenty of
time
black zero rookie seven
d4
time out why is victorious i won the
time yes okay
i won the game i didn't realize toggy's
clock was so low
wow okay good game toggy
80 moves ah
i feel so accomplished
knight takes d4 oops um
i just want to turn off the sound thing
that was a lot that's a long game
yeah there's so many uh
fork tricks i tried to bait tagi
into taking my e3 pawn
yeah this position i have to work on my
acting
and and then this was a really funny
situation where the
like it was hard for the queen to find a
square because these squares are off
limits
eventually he got frustrated and sacked
and the knight was really tricky
yeah these pawns never got i guess i
eventually got connected
i thought i was going to lose here
yeah rook f3 is not possible
oh oh yeah then here i i just forgot
where the rook was
man okay well it's two to one
it's gonna be a very long match this
increment
um yeah we started what slightly less
than an hour ago
anyway let's continue um
hey oh i was looking at the
the computer thing
so i made one lunder towards the end
oh yeah i hear g2 wins i think i realize
this but
it's hard to to actually spot that in
time pressure
um yeah let's uh let's continue
i think i i need the increments if i
don't have the increment i just i flag
because i can't really
effectively pre-move let's
continue analysis board
yeah okay continue
white
it's raining out when people can hear
the rain or the thunder
anyway um let's continue
i'll mix up the opening maybe i'll play
more aggressively
speech synthesis ready
i i have an opening idea actually let's
play
e4 novelty e4 at least a novelty for
this match
d5 he's playing scandi oh because he's
scandinavian
icelandic plays a scandi let's take
play knight c3 too let's take it queen
takes d5
like c3 knight c3
who's trying to say queen of fight uses
queen queen
queen five oh my partner mouse eric
oh sorry is that better
hey that's better uh let's play bishop
d3
bishop d3
sorry about that
and the thunder
the other day it was rainstorming and
there was so much thunder and the lights
were flickering
but i guess if the lights flicker
i won't know i won't even know if the
stream i guess
check white two minutes 45 seconds
knight g2 knight f6
kingside castles i'm very happy with
this opening
very happy even though i haven't won
anything yet what
v6 b6 kingside b6
b6 b6 okay
yeah taki likes to play this b6 move
like he's played at every game
and we'll play knight d4 knight d4
i need to get my dark thread bishop out
lee's
[Music]
let's play knight knight d b5 knight db5
f3 will come with a bam
bishop e7 yeah i can't take on c7 right
away
or can i probably not
i can't see silent no it just works
let's play after three
taki going for those cheap checkmates
okay so my king's defended tagging c7
attacking the queen queen has to retreat
and then
not sure what the game plan is
queen d7
yeah i'll play 92
i play 92 knight e2 there we go
because my knight on b5 is going to get
kicked e6
or not play b3
b3 expecting bishop c5
yeah so i'm trying to like c6 apply
knight c6 c6 apply these like
principles when you're down material you
don't want to trade bishop e2
i want to keep pressure keep as much
kind of tension
as possible a6
hmm probably knight eighth
almighty
not thrilled with this
my bishop is just really misplaced yeah
knight b4 is a good move
i guess i'll play knight f4 knight f4
trying to complicate matters
knight takes d3 okay no it takes e3
if i have some weird knights in the
center
some idea of knight e5 bishop's e5 check
king h1 always picking each one
bishop d4 now taki's just going for
trades
that's a good strategy let's play rook a
e1
rook are you one just want to optimize
the pieces that i have
bishop takes c3 bishop takes c3 actually
don't mind that tree inside castles
cycle oh queenside castles i'll play 95.
knight e5 attacking queen
so i have the only dark sword bishop on
the board
black has only like bishop on the board
queen e7
queen e7 a4 a4 black also has only queen
on the board
taki trying to attack me
i guess i'll play a5 a5 have to attack
attack back b5
interesting
play d3 d3
g5 wow toggy being ultra aggressive
i want to play a6 let's do it
wait a six
okay oh i can't play a6 because black
has upon a6
i've got the pawn moved
and g5 was a good move too or was it
it probably was
i don't know what to do here thanks for
subbing
ricky too play rookie 2 and be solid
i have a pretty good grasp of the the
position rook h7
play rook 1 rook fe 1
just piling up on 95.
d2 bishop d2
you played rook h7 so they're still on
other works on d8
all i need is like one queen blender
that's all i need
one bow test gabbit white
one minute 13 seconds black
one minute twenty seconds
night four
trying to avoid trades f6
that's a good move
f6 is like always a good night g4
h64 oh oh the pawn was still on
ah i was envisioning the palm in h4 for
some reason
that's not good bishop takes f4
g takes f4 f takes g4
let's now i'm down a queen and bishop
e5
g7 in back eric
in back g7
i'm confused rook
play h3 h3
he takes f4 rook takes e7 hey i won the
queen
white 0 minutes 42 seconds
black one minute 16 seconds
i'm pretty sure my rook is hanging right
so he played f6
i think i should just resign unless
what's happening rick takes e7
room takes e7 oh he pre-moved oh
rookie 2 he pre-moved i resign
yeah i resign i resign i'm just dead
resigned i was waiting i was waiting for
him to move but he pre-moved this that's
why i got confused
okay three to one yeah that was a
i mean he played pretty cleanly in that
game
and i think oh i guess at this point my
knights just kind of trapped
but okay i should take on that f4 here
and then knight g6
wasn't looking so good rook tattoo
anyway well played hey are we supposed
to what's up
alexa what is that alexa what's up
from reuters tv
here are the top stories
play stockfish level one blindfolded
lol wait what am i doing um
in portland oh alexa stop it okay
um oh rematch
let's abort and i'm aborted rematch
oh i missed the tiger oh man
oh thanks for the all the new bits and
follows
and you're welcome duffy happy to save
your life
do i need a break oh i need more tea
forgot my tea
the tea is now lukewarm okay three to
one still room
i actually like the opening that game um
i just i probably shouldn't misplace my
bishop on d3 like that
ever again
wait okay so sound is on let's do this
okay e4
let's see what toggy wants to play
white d5 okay let's repeat the opening
queen takes d5
knight c3 knight c3 queen e6 check
yeah very happy with this bishop v2
knight f6
d4 okay no mercy
no mercy
maybe i should have played that f3 first
knight e4
oh you just wants to trade
together 391 knight d1
i don't know if those taggies are more
distracting for me or for
for my opponent i can live with it
i'm used to it by now queen d5
queen d5 knight f3 okay so he's just
kind of moving the same pieces
the knight and the queen i'm just trying
to develop
as quickly as possible bishop g4 knight
d5
or 95 knight e3
knight e3 attacking d5
take my knights queen a5 check omg
it's back to 100 again behind haha
i actually like that trade for me
oh thank you bless you too
wait so my knights on e3 knight c6 he
played pawn f5
i think i'll play b4
hmm maybe a4 first
a4 and b4
g5 what's he doing okay b4 let's let's
do this
b4 i just want to win the queen
that's all i want to do
also f5 b6 i think f5 is hanging i'm so
glad the voice is back when i was here
last time it was gone
oh interesting probably from the wizard
danny
let's play knight d5
i can also take there's there's a lot of
great looking options here
so i can play knight c4
maybe knight c4 is the way to go
knight c4 yeah this queen is just a
goner
queen a6 i played b5 and then bye-bye
your queen
oh no you're queen oh no
yeah my queen is long gone
i miss it but i have to live without it
maybe someday my queen will be reborn
i need to make a past pawn
italia's realizing his doom
g5 and g5 was not the most productive
move
y g4 oh g4 okay let's take on
b6 it takes b6
oh he pre-moved that okay and now i
guess i'll take on e4
bishop takes e4 f takes e4 rookie one
so he's still up like a minor piece i
believe still has a bishop on f8
and that on c6 okay h5
uh let's take that
rick takes e4
queen side castles
okay
he has pawns on h5 g4 it's still e7
i think i'm going to play bishop f4 just
develop
it's on c6 bishop on that favor kind of
h8 okay
have a nice kind of a4 b4 c3 d4
setup
i might go for uh for rook not for um
for pawn a5 because my rooks on a1
bishop h6
he wants to trade
it's a decent move actually maybe i can
take it eric is like iro the team master
mmm
i think i'll take that bishop takes h6
rook takes h6
okay you won yeah so i'm down at night
what's up on camera i'm have a pawn
train rookie
wait i was just hallucination i was
thinking the knight has access to d5 but
it doesn't
so i could play b5 here
so play b5 b5 hitting the knight
i'm going to win e7 985
rick takes e7 okay i'm still slightly
worse
like objective seven that's interesting
i have two pawns for the knight
knights out of player 38
let's play rook g7 maybe the sheep goes
bar
rook g7 baha
geez knight c4 let's see for
king of one
king f1
okay so active rook knight b2
like b2 he's trying to confuse me
i guess i can play a5 a5
he just wants two a5 oh the pawn was on
b6
oh the king's on d8 so i have rook g8
and rook
8 rook g8 check
kd7 rk8
that's on b2 b6 b6
b6 b6 what does that say
b6 e6
did the epon never move b6 b6
b6 sbe6
confused i guess the epon never moved
hmm
take a seven okay seven
wait there's no point okay seven there's
no point on e7 wait
i'm so confused v6
knight d1
i thought i played a5 and he took on
oh he had double beep oh he had double b
pawns because he recaptured
he played knight d2 okay i understand
that
so i have rook a5
wait i don't have rook
because he played b6 okay let's play
king e2
what just happened
what what just happened
king e2 kenny two there we go okay
knight take c3 check oh king d3
kd3 the position's crumbling takes b5
my pawn rook a rocket
ah such a nice game too
[Music]
king of five there goes all my pawns
yeah these double b-pawns threw me off
a4
v4
is my tongue b5 a3
ken takes h5 okay ready too
kim takes g4 interesting rook takes f2
kg3
b2 h4 a2
h5
knight d6
knight d6
h h6
knight f5 check oh good move
good move duh king f4 knight takes h6
king g5 knight f7 check
king f6 knight d6
g4 okay still have hope one pass pawn
against like three past fawns in the
night
check the e4 check oh no
no king f5
king of five knight takes g5 ken takes
g5
king d6
king g6 b4
king g7 b3
rook f8
a1 promotes the queen rick f6 check
king d7
[Music]
rookie six
rookie to check
what oh it's discovery check oh fancy
uh king h7 rick takes e6
da okay i resigned ah
white resigned i wanted to set up some
weird let's
see this is a bad move
i don't know why
i don't know why i was thinking there i
again i was lost i wanted to set up like
this final stalemate trap
i was hoping for this move and then it
wasn't going to work
so what happened there
yeah i was still envisioning the pawn on
on a7 so knight b2 was a good move
okay i have to regroup
oh yeah four to one right four to one
man
good game toggy let's uh let's continue
still hope i mean i feel like i've had
hope in most of these games
um it takes a5 this game is just
need to to stay focused thanks to pin
1077 for subbing all right let's rematch
and then
game start support and remember okay
game start okay let's do this
uh good luck and goodbye okay i'm really
liking the opening
e4 e4 there we go okay
we might see him switch things up
e5 e5 e5 wow
so i'm going to play um a king's indian
attack
slightly different move order though
h6 interesting
d5
knight d2 knight c6
c3 okay so i'm restricting the knight so
he doesn't have these
annoying knight b4 moves d4 let's play
oh let's play c4
he's still gonna play knight b4 blinking
d1
knight before
why can't i type kingdom
okay queen f6
oh attacking me from all directions
maybe f3 here f3
i want to play a3 b4 soon
we played h6 so early
it moves like h6 so that sometimes i'll
just forget about
knight c6
all right let's play play g3 g3
bishop b4
he really wants to trade no trades like
b1
queen takes f3 check what
knight takes f3 what free queen
free queen okay i don't know if that was
i don't know what that was about gambit
knight f6 okay so i've i just won the
queen
i'm only down the pawn right f6 let's
play um
a3 so all i have to do is keep track of
the position
so knight went back to bishop d6 to c6
okay so let's play b4
b4 okay no mercy this time
b6 b6 b6
b6 okay some reason i have a hard time
like hearing that move
to bishop g2 bishop g2
bishop e7
can i play b5 and win the no i can't
there's too many defenders let's play
rook f1 rook f1
985
hmm
it's still tricky let's play g4 g4
knight f4 bishop takes f4
e takes f4 and b5 b5
i should be winning the d-pawn
knight e5 e5 oh my d-pawn
both our d-pawns are hanging
it's a weird position
if i take
hmm confusing move
maybe i'll just play key too can you too
just defend everything
knight takes f3 bishop takes f3
okay bishop p5
let's play knight d2 knight d2
and then g6 wait where's my other
minor piece
g6 he played g6 okay
don't play bishop g2 bishop g2
so he has two bishops i have nine bishop
let's play knight f3 knight f3
having a hard time like remembering the
structure bishop g7 bishop g7
play a4 a4
f5 ah that was his plan
if i can take
let's take once with the g
pawn gf5 g takes f5
and i'll probably move back
[Music]
wait where'd the bishop went to h8 or g7
g takes f5 a4 bishop g7
g7 okay knight d2 okay
white two minutes 16 seconds
black two minutes zero seconds okay up
on time
let's go
bishop f6
bishop f6
so i think i can take that
replace f4 bishop g5
now rook f2
rook f1 safer
oh both move oh both rooks can move uh
rook path
f1 f1
okay so if we could train on e4 bishop
takes d2
[Music]
returning before i take on f8 first
actually i don't need to f takes e4
let's play bishop before bishop takes e4
rook takes f1 rook takes f1 okay
everything d takes e4 okay
king e7 kd3
okay i'm pretty sure the structure if
hans
brook rook g8 rook g8 wait free pawn
can take d4
i have a4 b5 c4 e4 rook g3 and h3
yes
a7 b6 c7 he's attacked my pawn
should probably play h4 here h4
okay don't mind that
i'll play rook
play rook um g1
rook g1
i just want to win h pawn
rook takes a4 rook g6
check or no not check so kings on e7 or
d7
a6 it's just a rook ending now
oh a6 is a good move let's take it
rick takes a6
so he can take he can play b5 i think
i'm okay against both moves
my idea is just to win the pawn
white one minute 10 seconds black
one minute 48 seconds
so he has plenty of time to think which
translates to my time sipping tea
yeah i'm up i'm up upon so pawns on
a6 c4 e4 and
h4 it's your move it's my move
rick takes a six oh four
six h6 thanks for that dwight zero
minutes 43 seconds
what happened there black rock a8 yes i
missed it your turn
thanks for that let's play e5 e5
there we go
maybe when i typed clock i just got
confused
king d7 d7 let's play h5 h5
okay so up upon so c4 e5 h5
these pawns on b6 c7
rook g8
g6 g6
idea h6 coming
rook h8 h6
king eight
king of five
king of seven of the e6
king f8 ooh
liking f6 king f6 just trapping his king
and rook
in the corner of sadness seven not e6 e6
c6
tricky but not tricky
but kind of tricky i don't know how do i
make progress
some twist to zugzwang let's play king
g5 kg5
b5
see takes b5
[Music]
oh it's my move forecast six recaps
pre-moved
e7 rook g6
b4 rook g7 check
rick take g7 check your h kin takes e6
g8 promotes to queen check king e5
queen b3 king d4
of four king c5
king e3 king b5 king d3
king c5
queen c4 check king b6
king a5
king c4
king a6
queen takes b4 king a7
king a8 king c6
king a7 queen
checkmate it's so difficult when he
pre-moves
and i don't hear my move confirmation
and i just get confused
man okay
gg another long game
so yeah the key moment was here
target got gotcha baited with my f pawn
oh the sip t thinks double khan he's
gonna sip tea anyway
i should have a command for like linking
this extension
this is a chrome extension but you can
also use uh
speech settings
i actually don't understand the comment
from ezra zev
consider making the notation natto or
another alphabetical alphabet
so i can tell which file it is i don't
understand that
um feel free to elaborate but i start i
think i understand
the game start the files
okay four to two
let's do this good luck toggy
actually tiger doesn't need luck i need
all the luck i can get
all right um let's put e4 again
liking this opening best by test
at some point yeah like i'm i'm trying
to
to do the math how long this match could
take because we're probably not even
halfway through
also what he's thinking d5 okay
all right so the game's beginning
let's uh let's take dd5 queen takes d5
c3 knight c3
queen d8 um playing like john
bartholomew so i can't play d4 here
i guess i'll play bishop c4 bishop c4
just develop
e6 e6 e6 okay
play d3 d3
a6 a4
i'm preventing b5 bishop d7
knight g2
bishop b4 bishop d2
okay all the minor pieces developed
we might end up trading bishop for night
but that's okay
kingside castles
bishop d6 um
interesting
okay you won okay just trying to make my
pieces happy
c6
some exotic play by tigey i guess i'll
play
play bishop b3 let's see
queen c7
oh he wants to castle queen side maybe
play
actually don't know what to play here
we can see some maybe i'll play a play
try 85
kind of gambling upon
very weird development e5 e5
e5
uh-huh you play f4
f4
king side castles my position's getting
strange
i'm gonna play f5 f5
i'm trying to create some attack
knight g4
like g4
interesting
play h3 h3
bishop c5 check i was slightly scared of
that
but and how bad could it be
wait my next time on e2 and c3
let's play um i have to play
tricky
try rook f3 rook f3
i'm trying to trap the knight knight
takes f5
knight takes f5 work f5
rook takes f5
oh no the bishop was on d7
okay let's fight let's play g4 g4
i only lost exchange bishop p6
e6 good move let's play knight g3 not g3
bishop takes b3 c takes b3
bishop b4 bishop b4
there's a b4 really don't have much left
let's um let's try an attack
and a fight
wait so i have bishop on d2 knight on c3
still
rook on queen takes a5
e1
oh
yeah where's my plan b rook
hi rookie four rookie four
bishop takes c3 b takes c3
no no no no i won't play bishop take c3
that's okay though i guess
i forgot i have to type capital b or d2
to c3
knight d7 d7
hey rook rookie two
it's not a great position one minute 21
seconds
black two minutes five seconds
repeat c4
u okay queen c5
bishop e3 bishop p3
queen b4
h4 attack queen takes b3
oh okay h5
let's keep it tagging queen d1 check
no my rook
rookie one queen takes e1 check i was
hoping he would pre-move queen takes e2
but
okay h5 queen takes you one check
queen that was a really unfortunate game
so my main mistake okay yeah i mean this
is
unacceptable bishop so i should have i
should have taken
and then position still may be playable
okay targi let's go again so taki is
five
two to five
i'm wondering if
if we can make it like 3-0 and i play i
play with invisible pieces
game start but i don't want to really
change the match midway through game
aborted
game start okay let's go
um yeah good luck
and wait it's five to two right
it's five to two i might wanna update
the command
okay let's do this
let's play e4 wait
what oh e4 e4
g6 oh
h4 h4
e5 e5 okay
this is actually interesting this is
some kind of
interesting oh what we call this
let's play each probably h6
maybe losing a pawn knight g4
play d3 d3
that's a really funny opening queen f6
tag you want some mimi again
let's play f3 f3
i think the knights draft tiger fell for
an opening trap
has no squares he should have uh should
have taken on e4
instead of knight g4
knight takes h6 yeah okay bishop h6
bishop takes h6
oh he pre-moved that rook takes h6
i'm not good at like queen b6 realizing
the pre-moves
queen b6 queen b6 queen b6 that's a
really good move
that's like a pro move
wow i think i got counter trapped
i'll play knight t2 knight d2
queen takes g1
i got counter trapped
knight c4
still a little bit of hope
b5
b5
playing really well this game
oh knight e5 knight takes e5
queen e3 check bishop e2
queen takes h6 i just want to resign i'm
resigning that was a really bad game i
lost in 12 months
resigned i thought he fell into my trap
h6 that's some deep opening preparation
queen b6 rick takes h6 also this is
winning too
or this there's three moves which just
destroy me
these moves would hit the rook but also
threaten queen c1 and winning
winning the other rook it's incredible
that both rooks like end up hanging to
the queen
[Music]
e5 knight f6 h6 this is a bad opening
plan
i should probably take i should take and
play d3 all right
rematch game start d4
game aborted otagi gives me queen arts
that could be an interesting match
rematch
tagi might be a secret gm i'm pretty
sure iceland has a
the highest like rate
grand masters per capita of any country
so if you're from iceland you have the
highest chance of beco of like being a
grand master
all right
okay let's do this let's play oh you
know i haven't played yet c4
not played the london
it's london time
b6 b6 b6
b6 b6 b6 okay
b6 let's play e4 e4 bishop b7
bishop d3
okay so this time toggy is basically
playing my like hippo approach
knight c6
i'm just trying to follow opening
principles c3
d5 d5 let's play
play e5 so this is the type of structure
i really enjoy
the winning connect for nice uh
what queen c8 we can see it all
he's done this before too
he wants to play bishop a6
or he wants to play queen g4
intriguing move queen g4
wow so he's he has so much confidence
from the previous game
just destroying me with his queen let's
play g3
g3 winning connect four on the other
side
so i have a nice beautiful pawn chain
a5 hmm
bishop p2 try and chase away this queen
queen f5 bishop e3
i just want to develop
queen e4 really
wow it's actually working
is it
that's crazy
i didn't think it was gonna work
wow
i guess i'll have to try and trap the
queen play bishop f2 bishop f2
queen takes h1 bishop of three okay
let's try and trap the queen
queen takes h2
knight d2
well played man these queens are tricky
i wish i had one of those queen h6
queen h6 yeah i don't think the queen's
getting trapped
i guess i'll play play bishop e3 bishop
p2
i meant to play bishop e3 that's okay
though
queen e6
i still have more space let's play gg4
f6 i'm download let's play f5 f5
i'm down the queen and a rook but look
at my pawn
queen d7 e6 e6 wow
queen d6
this pawn structure is so nice it's not
going to last though
unless we knight f1 knight f1
bishop h6 bishop g3
okay
queen d8
bishop f3
bishop takes f1 king takes f1
it's actually kind of beautiful g6 g6
g6 let's play knight e2 knight e2
g takes f5 g takes f5
9 h6
bishop h5 check check
one legal move right one legal move
hahaha
two minutes five seconds
knight f7 bishop f7 bishop
oh that was so nice that was a nice
gambit
gambit paid off oh these pawns
for a moment i was second guessing
myself that this bishop had moved
so that's revenge for like being
annoying with the queen
queen e6 f queen this is really nice
knight f1 oh i was still envisioning the
bishop here i thought like
he could take but he can't take g knight
g6 yeah oh thanks for the sub gifs
are we supposed to gifting 10 subs
thanks for that no when he played g6 my
um my eyes lit up but you can see my
eyes light up
because they were covered but this was
yeah this is so nice to see
it's already okay h5 here or move the
bishop
black's still winning but okay
so six to three game aborted
let's do this let's do this shout out to
are we supposed to
gifting subs to
[Music]
various people
okay let's put on the blindfold
and there's still time to maybe come
back
okay good luck
okay good luck to me play d4 d4
undefeated with this opening so far
knock c6 okay oh knight c6 ooh let's
play d5
d5 let's have a fun position
f4 f4
knight g6 now
maybe h4 h4 i just want to trap the
knights
e6 e6 is a good move
i'll play h5 h5
knight 67 86 e7
nice okay let's uh let's take on e6 he
takes e6
d takes e6 e4
majestic checkmate oh thanks yeah that
was very majestic
b6 it's a fitting word for that b6 b6
i'll play knight c3 knight c3 bishop b7
knight f3 yeah it's time to develop
the first five moves of this game were
like just complete shenanigans
which is not following any opening
principles
h6 h6
bishop p3 okay continuing to develop
okay i want the queen side castle
oh now i can queen's castle queen side
castles
yeah he's been doing this uh this queen
c8 bishop a6 idea
which i don't mind bishop h6 i don't
think i mind
bishop a6
i mean yeah we're gonna have to trade
bishops probably
we'll play i'll play g4
g4
bishop takes f1 now
rook hf1 rook h takes f1 okay
to do
f5 f5 so
because i only have a dark squared
bishop i want my pawns on light squares
and the kingside pawns they're on some
nice light squares
ricky i don't want to trade
play rook one ricky one
so it's a weird king side because ty has
knights on
g8 e7 he takes it
he takes f5 he takes out
let's take with
the pawn he takes f5 thanks for subbing
kd7 d7 okay let's play 95
knight t5 check and then knight f7
unless he moves back to guess he could
move back to he hates
this looks fun though
it's a little bit reminiscent of last
game where i'm just like squeezing
the structure is nice pieces are nice
it's a very difficult decision because
either has to allow knight f7 or he has
to
put the king back on e8 and then b7
white two minutes 39 seconds
black one minute 42 seconds
the question is what to do in bishop f4
bishop
i'm just going to be patient like keep
building up
i have knight g6 knight g6
rook h7 man what is this
i guess i have knight b5 knight b5
i like the position nice
uh various attacks
and pieces are all coordinating nicely
i probably want to double up soon on the
e file
i can play rookie six king f7 f7
so i can take on c7
debating what to take with
maybe i should take with bishop
actually it's a big choice
i wish it takes
no let's take with knight
objectively this is probably better now
it takes c7
our black is very very stuck
so if i could take my nylon g6 and we
trade
oh queen g2 aggressive
i'll play 96 knight e6 it's not over
though
it takes work to break through
it oh he wants to meet me
play c3
this isn't simple anymore
maybe bishop d2
bishop d2 that's tricky
queen takes g4 yeah
hey rook i'm actually not sure what to
do here
like it looks so nice but what to do
bishop c3
positions crumbling
takes f5
save knight knight f4 that's not what
they wanted to do
but it's life
i didn't quite see it
i feel like i was very close to a win
white 0 minutes 32 seconds
black 0 minutes 24 seconds
93
rook g1
queen g5
king b1
queen
queen f5 i take that
rook g2 no i want to play rook g3
time out oh did i why is victoria oh i
wanted time
i wanted to play rook g3 oh
i won on time the position was yeah it
was a really weird position
it was not um queen knight e5 check
king d7 rook d8
d what happened in this game
there's like like this position
it's so pleasant because all these
pieces are stuck
um and my pieces are fully optimized i
just didn't see
the dt the meat knight f4 real quick
yeah stockfish has no fear even in
positions like this
otagi saying oh you played 94.
oh maybe there is lag
g2 oh you flagged ah
okay well
the match goes on so
this is maybe closer than expected
okay game start
six to four
game aborted oh yeah rematch okay game
start
all right let's play actually like d4
i've been liking the positions i'm
getting
i'm still undefeated with d4 as well
maybe i'll play stonewall
bishop d7 bishop d7
wait that's a weird move play bishop d3
bishop d3
no offense to that move
knight f6 f3
f3 is also a bit weird blind i'm
restricting the knight i might want to
play g4
a6 a4 oh he wanted to play bishop b5 and
trade off bishops i see
no thank you i am getting a sense of
like his style of just wanting to to
trade
e6 but sometimes when you're
you're too anxious to trade 92 it leads
to misplacing pieces
h5 h5
i'll play what to play here
maybe b3 b3
some ideas like just bishop b2 knight d2
g5
interesting play knight d2 first
what's going knight d2
knight c6 c3
e5
oh e5
play bishop b2 bishop e2
g4 g4
wow really confusing me
can i take take on e5
d takes e5
no it takes e5
[Music]
hmm
your blindfold is upside down forehead
before oops wait what
b4 knight takes d3 check no i don't need
to play b4 3
has it been upside down this whole time
uh cd3
oh my pawns on c3 i resigned i resigned
this is really bad why i was really bad
black is victorian to play b4 i meant to
take the knights
e5 which was illegal because i i
yeah this spawn on c3 destroyed me
e5 g4 knight d
knight c6 c3
knight c6 i guess when i played c3 it
just didn't register
wow that was really bad okay
well thanks for letting me know
blindfold will
never again be upside down let's rematch
it's four to seven
i'm only six games away from winning
this match
yeah people can see the score right here
game start
i think so that game that game was just
terrible because he confused me with
putting his pieces on weird squares
so let's let's not fall into his son
before
his weirdness stick with
classical play d5
playing f3 knight f3
maybe going for london but we'll see
bishop g4 knight e5
yeah this is what i was hoping for
actually because now the bishop gets
kicked
in various ways
oh but my c pawn's not defended
bishop e6 okay that's
very pleasant to hear
hmm
actually not sure like the best way to
develop
i'll just play bishop before bishop
treat the cycle london
knight d7
knight c3 i'm okay with trading
at least one pair of miners
blindfolded still upside down forehead
no it's not good try though
h6 h6
queenside castle queen side castles
so g5 is probably coming maybe i should
have played h4
but okay g5 i'll play bishop g3 maybe
later h4
it's also not gf6
knight g f6 okay f3 i was also going to
say
there's an idea to play e4 no it takes
e5
interesting d5
d takes e5
985 yeah i don't want to trade
i'll play it looks ugly well i'll play
bishop
we both have our bishops on ugly squares
but yeah i want to leave the nylon h5
eventually play g4 g5
g4 g4 knight g7
now probably like bishop f2
bishop f2 the problem with black's
position is everything is in the way of
each other
like the knight doesn't want to be on g7
says the ship doesn't want to be on e6
can i play e4
queen c7 ah so my pawn's hanging
i'll play bishop g3 bishop g3
queen side castles oh
interesting play bishop
d3 d3 d takes e4
play knight e4 knight takes e4
oh no my apon my a2 pawn bishop takes a2
b3 okay i don't know if that was a
like bait or if bishop takes a2 queen a5
but the whole idea is to trap the bishop
king b2
rook a1 incoming
e6
e6 is probably a good move
i'm probably in trouble
oh dear
oh this is really bad
oh
where are my pieces
this is really bad
i have a bishop on d3
94
oh something went terribly wrong here
let's play okay
okay one don't hurt me
please don't hurt me
queen i check don't do it don't do it
please don't do it queen b4 check
king b2 okay he's into it
i was close i was really close
queen e3 check draw bishop b4 check
king c4 don't do it
be five times check me i saw that coming
i just i
couldn't stop it oh
yeah he did it okay bishop reflected
mate that's brutal
always repeat yeah that was really
brutal
i mean probably beautiful from his
perspective
almost as beautiful as that bishop f7
made i had earlier
man it's a four
[Music]
b3 e6 yeah i can't stop this
i thought this was a trickiest move but
oh i had knight d6 here i should have
played knight t6
yeah my g6 actually keeps me alive and
then then i actually trapped the bishop
oh well okay
tiger got some mercy there thank you
xavier 3x for subbing with prime
it was inside out what no maybe
i don't know
it's a nice blindfold it's like 12 bucks
on on amazon
it's quality she gets sponsored by
whatever company makes use
game aborted okay let's get revenge
um let's mix up the opening let's play
e4
wait never mind i found one knight c3 ng
ng ng ng and
ng nice job good luck rosen
well thanks for that knight c3 knight c3
oh so tigey's perplexed queen e6 check
okay i i like this opening bishop p2
the queen doesn't want to be on e6
knight f6
i'll play so the question is how do i
actually punish this let's play d4
d4 it's hard to punish without having a
queen
knight e4 hmm
[Music]
didn't we have this position before i
played knight e1
or knight d1 knight d1
this feels vaguely familiar
just avoiding trades these openings are
so bizarre
knight c6 c3
queen's still on e6
i want to play knight f3 and castle and
rookie one
and eventually win the queen
queen g6 oh
so i can't really play another three
unless i can
can i get away with it knight f3
queen g2 rook g1
i'll play knight e3 knight e3 it's a
safer move defending the the g
pawn redeveloping the knight
eventually i'll play probably bishop d3
and i'll still look to castle
no it takes f2 what
is queen c2 coming queen c2 would be
nice
queen f6 check
all out e5
fancy
so hitting the queen and unleashing the
rook and pinning the pawn
so i'm defending my knight on f3 i'm
also threatening the the fork on c7
and threatening to take the pawn with
check
i'm threatening three different captures
with chuck d6
queen d6 queen d6 okay so let's take e4
knight d5 e4 rookie one
i played brookie one knight d5 queen d6
i have a bishop on e2
i forgot about that i have a bishop on
you too
you have a bishop i know i know i know i
figured
i forgot i blocked the check ages ago
let's play maybe bishop c4
bishop c4 okay so now i'm actually
unleashing the rook now it all makes
sense
i'm not getting free material but
maybe i am because i'm tightening the
pawn
bishop p6 ooh
so i can wait this is confusing now i
can play bishop f4
bishop so hitting the queen my bishop's
defended by the knight
queen's gonna have to move back to
savannah d8
i can't complain with this queen d7
probably knight c7
knight take c7 check
this is a great great opening so far
take on e6
probably should take yeah because my
knight's hanging on that three
let's take on e6 without taking check
check well then i'll take on e4
finally f takes e6
rook takes e4
okay so i got a pawn
i'm up a minor piece
bishop d6
i think e6 is hanging
bishop takes e6
queen c7 bishop g5
bishop g5 bishop g5 check check
97
wait i'm i'm trying to remember the
position so i have bishops on
e6 and g5 not on f3
okay so queen queen's on c7
i guess i'll play rook play rook 81
okay you won it's a great position
i just have to orchestrate some kind of
checkmate
h6 yeah a good move
don't really want to take you can't
really play bishop h4 either because
then g5
play bishop d2 bishop d2
knight g6
interesting i think c4 is probably
called for
c4
knight f4
wait i still have a rook on e4
natalia wants to play knight d3
i think c5 still might be good
let's try it c5 c5 knight d3 king e2
knight d3 check kimi 2
knight takes e1 now cd6 say take e6
because i hit the queen
and i'll win back the knight
maybe with the bishop queen 66.
oh my ah that pawn's not defended it's
still okay
let's take king or bishop
with the bishop bishop takes e1
so i have three minors in a row
against something d5
d5 against queen and two rooks
hmm
yeah let's hide king two at least try
and hide
queen takes a2 no
bishop c3 bishop c3 so at least i have
peace harmony
queen b1 let's say i'm threatening to
take on g7
who is that standing behind you
probably the green screen hopefully
uh oh my god
rookie two he too king's on d8 i think
where'd the king go think the king's on
d8
so some idea of 95.
a complicated position king c7
c7
take on g7
b6
knight d4 okay just trying to use my
minor pieces
effectively
rook takes e6
really he takes e6
bishop bishop
okay
so i basically have knight bishop for
queen g6
g3
queen f6
rook e4 okay so trying to just defend
everything
king c5 interesting
play b4 b4 check
ah that was a bad move
king c4 you can see for
the king i'll play key 3.
uh another really weird position can
text before
i don't see any great discoveries
timeout black is victorious
i thought ah i i guess i had the time
warning from earlier
ah my time
oh we were both in time trouble too
that was a cool position
vision v6 is interesting
all right i have to win the next six
games to win this match
let's do this nothing's behind me
except the green screen
that was unfortunate i mean i was really
proud of my king takes b4
my defensive setup like everything was
defended
okay game aborted okay let's do this
start
okay blindfold is right okay let's um
i'm fine repeating the same opening
actually
oh yeah e4
e4 okay d5
it takes d5 queen takes d5 knight c3
yeah very fine with this queen five
yeah we had this earlier i think i'll
just play d3 here d3
and then if you encounter the bishop on
the kings side
e6
also play bishop bishop
bishop b4 is coming
man i'm a little bit perplexed this
queen on f5 annoys me
i played g3 can probably get away with
g3
g3
expecting bishop c5
bishop's e5 either f4 or knight h3
i'll play knight h3 983
so defending the pawn it's an ugly
square for the knights but
i just want a complete development and
eventually play knight f4
white 2 minutes 36 seconds
attacking again uh
i guess bishop g2 bishop g2
g4 coming g4 g4 knight f4 knight f4
if e5 i have bishop e4
there should be four queen f6 knight d5
like cd5 actually
bishop d4 wow
okay so he just wants to trade
i can probably just castle
let's castle kingside castles
h5 interesting
maybe a4 a4
h4
okay i have no fury let's find knight p5
knight b5
this is the whole idea of a4
so i'm attacking the bishop i'm
attacking
c7 tag is attacking my king side
could get very messy
white 2 minutes 25 seconds
black 2 h6 g3
wow so i could take the bishop first
let's do that no it takes d4
if takes h2 i play king h1
g takes h2 check king h1
yeah i'm using the black pawn as a
shield
to shut down the h file
so i want a piece
at the cost of upon being d5
queen c5 c5
play visit e3 bishop p3 so i have all my
minor pieces
in the game
and the queen is queen is black's only
developed piece queen e7
queen e7 okay
the question is how to how to continue
maybe you work after you won
rook just get to the e file
and some idea of knight uh
knight f5
or knight d5
knight f6
okay
okay i have an idea i'm gonna put the
bishop back on d2 bishop d2
and then maneuver it to c3
interesting let's play business e3
bishop c3
dwight one minute 59 seconds okay
zero minutes 56 seconds oh that's very
good
struggling bishop d7
so i have knight f5 here
knight f5 a crazy move
i have some pins in the position all i
want to do is pin and win
queen c5
pretty sure that's a mistake because i
have knights
oh it's actually tricky
no that's definitely a mistake i have
bishop
this should take f6 the brook is hanging
queen takes f5
bishop takes h8 queen takes f4
oh i don't have a pawn on g3 oh
that's unfortunate
there goes my knight and most of my hope
should be five bishop
ah that's really unfortunate queen takes
up two i have to go for the dirty flag
let's play play rook f1 rook f1
losing all my pawns queen takes c2
rookie c1
queen takes d3 i was hoping he'd take on
b2 and not realize my bishop
uh rook c7
what's the damage let's play rook c7
repeat c7
bishop c6 this is actually funny because
i can take on c6
no it takes c6
oh there's a knight on b8 oh
oh that's bad i was thinking that
there's no knight on b
i was going to win the rook and then
that's really bad play a5 a5
yeah i'm pretty much toast here
i guess i can try and go for dirty flag
bishop bishop g3
queen b5
d1
queen takes b2
and i'll play e6 i guess i can't
bishop two
queen takes up two ah my bishop bishop
takes c6 check
b takes c6 rookie heck
king e7 hmm taggy knows what's up
um let's play rook
e8 rookie h it's a crazy rook it's a mad
rook
just take my rook king f6
what takes e6 check
kenji seven g7 or g6
rook g6 check king f8
rook g8 check king e7
rookie heck kd6
rook e6 rookie 6 check
king c5
rick takes c6 check
king b4
rook c4 check king takes a5
king takes a5 okay four rook a4 check
king b5
right before check king c5
rp5 check king d4
rook d5 check king e4
rookie 5 check
king of four
request by check king three
rookie 5 check king f3
wow this is tricky uh
what king f3 recap
i was losing anyway king g3 i i ran out
of checks
i tried that's my last trick
so bishop f2 is actually intentional
even though it's still
that's still losing wow
well played tagi so tagi won i didn't
didn't suffer from 10 losses
actually i did suffer from 10 losses but
not in a row
it was ten to four final score
in the beginning i asked for predictions
i'm curious if anyone predicted that
yeah if i take the queen then king takes
queen
and i'm not stalemated and then it's
black's just mating
so this is this is why like you
shouldn't resign especially when you
have a rook
because there's weird situations this is
called mad rook or crazy
rook um so hopefully people are
are inspired to never give up hope
until all hope is lost